i i just kind of want to start from the
from the position i don't know maybe
you've seen this list of things before
but the this is this is the original set
of goals that brian getz had had for the
the lambda project which came in with
java 8. so these these kind of five
goals that are here and these are sort
of roughly in order of importance i
would say
um
the the top two or three are kind of all
essentially equal first i mean these
three things kind of come together
but the expressiveness of the
programming and the better libraries
more concise and easy to read code those
are those are all key parts of the
lambdas project
and of course when we talk about lambdas
you know
that they go hand in hand with the other
changes which which came in java 8 in
particular streams
uh and default methods as well they're
really all part of the same uh language
changes which came in as part of java
rate which are all necessary
i think improved programming safety yes
it's definitely a thing which landers
help with but it's probably a lesser
goal compared to the top three and then
of course the the last point is is the
one that i think surprised people um
people thought i think initially that
that lambdas were going to lead to a lot
more data parallelism and you know ease
of use of parallel streams and
personally i just haven't seen it i have
not really
seen any real uptake of the use of
parallel streams and i think there are
some good reasons for that um but i
think that the data parallelism goal you
know that's why it's at the bottom it's
because it hasn't really been been seen
or achieved in practice
okay so yeah these were the goals of
lambdas and have they done them well i
think the answer is very much yes they
have lambdas have become you know just
ubiquitous just everywhere for java
programmers
and they they have become so much part
of the landscape now for for i think all
pretty much all working java programmers
so let's dig a bit deeper because you
might think okay you have lambdas you
have you have streams does that mean we
have functional programming well let's
let's let's just
dig dig slightly deeper here
what is the motivation of lambdas
well i i would argue and this is sort of
the the entry-level requirements of
functional programming this is the table
stakes if you like that
for functional programming you have to
be able to treat a piece of code piece
of logic as though it was data as though
it was a value
um and then what you you then want is
you want some nice syntax because you
don't want to have lots and lots of
ceremony for writing that you know down
the the inner class or whatever you're
going to represent your code as
so what you want is the ability to write
a small bit of code as let's say a
function literal
and if the ability to assign that into a
variable and pass it around like any
other value
now of course
in java we know that there are only two
types of value
there are primitive types of which there
are r8
um and then there are objects or
specifically object references really
um
a lambda is obviously not a primitive
type you know it's not an int it's not
any of the other primitive types so
therefore it's fairly obvious
that a lambda whatever it is a lambda
expression that's the the the full name
for these things an expression is a
thing which yields a value
so what value is yielded by a lambda
expression
and the only answer is is it's an object
so in in java
functions lambdas are objects
and we can think about like a really
simple case
let's think about an object which has no
fields
so just in in the same way that um
the the class java lang object does not
define any any fields
okay let's let's assume that we're going
to extend javaline object we're not
going to define any fields on this
uh
on this type at all and in addition to
the methods of object it's going to have
one
extra method that's what we call a
single abstract method or a sam type
yeah so
that that's kind of a useful thing
because it's sort of the minimal
representation we can have of a function
because it's got just a single method
obviously we're going to use java so
we'll be doing static typing so the
static type of of the the method in
terms of its return and it's its
argument types is going to matter
um but that's that's basically the
simplest representation of that we can
have of a what would be a function in
other languages
this concept of course has been around
in java since 1.1 and there are lots and
lots of tiny little inner classes that
pre-date lambdas which were basically
fulfilling this role
okay now of course which are eight we
actually get some proper syntax for this
you don't have to write in a classes
anymore you have things like the auto
conversion to the appropriate type
uh what's called target typing for java
lambdas uh and then of course you you
get also the nice effect that the the
name of the method doesn't matter
um so this is all you know fine and
lovely and this is just just lambdas as
you you know and love them today where
you've been been working with with java
8. what you might not know is that
underneath
the lambdas actually use an api which
was new in java 7
an api called method handles
because you see despite what you might
have thought and despite some
similarities
lambdas are not actually in the classes
in disguise
i think that might surprise some some
folks um whenever i i i tell people this
people actually sort of normally there's
a couple of people who sort of scratch
their head and think and think oh yeah
actually now you mention it they
they're not are they
um but some people have have not thought
about how lambdas might actually be
implemented and the answer is they use
this method handles api and they use a
thing called invoke dynamic which was
only introduced in java 7. it's actually
the only byte code that's ever been
added to the java specification
um and what it enables the the the
lambda implementation to do is to to
actually give a lot of flexibility and a
lot of future proofing
and some really nice things and and not
to to rely upon the in the classes
mechanism
anyway the
subject of this talk is is functional
programming not how cool lambda's and
their representation is so i think i
better leave that point there and move
on a little
the other thing which we should also
talk about is this distinction between
external iteration and internal
iteration because that's also going to
be going to be i think relevant when we
talk about functional programming so
just to remind you yes but i guess this
is probably refresher code
the original java collections do what's
called
external iteration
because what it what that means is you
know you call something like
the iterator method on a list and that
gives you back an iterator object
and the the code which is external to
the collection to the aggregate
the client code if you like has control
and the iterator is used to to step
through the collection
the list in this case
and to deal with one element at a time
so that is external control
in a certain sense it's also
exposing a bit of the internal
implementation detail
not a lot and and you know you don't
really think of this as being
encapsulation breaking
but it certainly is getting down into
the detail of the business of how the
collection is represented in a way which
perhaps you don't want to do
it's designed around iteration
it means you have to deal with
individual elements rather than dealing
with the the the collection of the
aggregate as a whole and there's a
certain amount of boilerplate and a
certain amount of ceremony that goes
along with it
so
what's what's the alternative well
obviously this one's called external
iteration then the alternative approach
that we're going to talk about is called
internal iteration
and this is actually what java streams
do
and now you see what we're doing is
we're kind of it's it's almost like an
inversion of control
pattern
if you you know i i i i don't mean
people often think about dependency
injection when they talk about that um
but this is i think a related pattern
what's happening is that the object
which represents the aggregate which now
is not a collection but a stream
it has control
control is internal
to the the aggregate
and the the internal implementation is
now is now kind of hidden away
you know this is a kind of
what's happening is the programmer is
saying what they want done
and not
specifying exactly how to do it
you know if you think about the methods
that are on stream it's things like map
and map basically says
take each element apply this function to
it
and give me back a new aggregate
so notice i'm being careful about my my
use of language here and saying
aggregate rather than collection
um there's a point in here about the
distinction between the collections and
the streams which is actually quite
important which we'll come back to
um but the the thing that i want to take
away from this is that this is this is
specifying
what needs to be done and when we
specify what needs to be done we are
talking about a function
so we are we are sort of implicitly
bringing in the concept of functional
programming because we're specifying
what needs to be done
um we're dealing with the the collection
or the aggregate as a whole and this
means that there's there's potentially
the spoiler plate and potentially a
ceremony as well
so that's that's all pretty good
um what else can we say well so
the question is if you know we now have
this sort of whirlwind tour of lambdas
do they make java functional
right so we do we have functions as
first class values
yes we do
that's fine because we we model a
function as a class
and and then therefore you can you can
just have an instance of a function is
represented as an object
we have the filter map reduce pattern
where you take a a java collection you
turn it into a stream and then you can
filter it you can map it you can reduce
it you know you can do other types of
transformation on it
and those sort of basic functional
operations are supported on the streams
that seems fine what else can we get
well we can do function composition you
know if you have two functions with the
appropriate static types you can chain
them together to build up composed
functions where you apply first one
function and then the other providing
the the generic types match up properly
so that's well that's really useful
all of the java rate code that we write
which uses lambdas of course relies upon
this and everything's lovely
but my question is
is is that enough
does that really make java a functional
programming language
um and so to answer that question
you might also want to ask another
question
which is is this one which is what makes
a language functional in the first place
so certainly all the things that i've
already talked about yes you need to
have functions as first plus values
absolutely you know filter map reduce
and the sort of things that javastream
brings in
that's all absolutely um essential
however
i would argue that other
functional programming languages other
languages which potentially are more
functional than java have a bunch of
other attributes as well
so i think that the next thing i want to
do is to talk about some of those
attributes
and let's just kind of build up a
scorecard of how well java actually
deals with each of those aspects
so what's my scorecard what are my
criteria well let's let's take a look at
this
seven items magnificent selling
okay so i want to talk about these these
things in order peer functions
immutability
higher order functions
tail recursion closures laziness and
carrying
um so don't worry if you don't know what
what all of these terms mean i'm going
to define each one as we go through and
i've only got about 15 20 minutes to do
this in so i'd better i'd better be
reasonably quick so i hope i've got some
some definitions which are reasonably
concise
and which makes some sense
so let's start the top with pure
functions so a pure function what's a
pure function well a pure function is a
function that doesn't alter the state of
any entity or object so it doesn't
change it the if you if
the the state of an object or it doesn't
alter any any state anywhere else in the
system either
so the other piece of jargon that people
use for this is that it's said to be
side effect free
okay
now the way to think about this is that
a function that's pure
behaves like a mathematical function
so you know if you if you see an
equation like y equals x squared
okay
well or f of x equals x squared
i can put the number three into that
um and the number three isn't altered by
doing that
but what i get out is another number so
i get out the number nine
um
you can also think of things like a
a function let's say from from strings
to to to ins
which is to take the length of an
individual string
well that's a that's a pure function it
takes in the string it doesn't alter it
in any way and it returns a number which
is the number of characters in the
string
so that would be another example of a
pure function takes in an argument the
string doesn't affect it and it returns
a result which depends only on the
arguments
an example of a function which is not
pure
is the current time
because it depends upon
the state of the
uh
of the of of the system clock and of
course if you call that function at
different times it's going to behave
differently so perhaps in my definition
i should say does not alter or depend
upon state that's probably a slightly
more accurate way of phrasing that i'll
uh i'll fix the slide for next time
so related to this is is the the notion
of referential transparency and
memorization and this is the idea that
what you can do is that you can if you
have a
function call
which which has some parameters in it if
you know the values of the parameters
you can replace the the function call
with the result
so that's that's connected to to those
two last items there
now the jvm of course has no functions
by the way it only has methods
so so we when we talk about about java
and the jvm we actually have to say pure
methods
um
so a pure method
in a jvm language is one that doesn't
modify object or static state
so i'm just going to use the the names
of the byte codes here it doesn't
contain a get field or put field and get
static or put static
because that's that's those are
uh would be would be relying upon
external state
you know obviously you can you can call
get field on one of your arguments but
not from your your own state as well
so it doesn't depend upon any external
object or static state and in particular
it doesn't depend upon any mutable state
because otherwise you could call the
function once and then you can call it
again and in between times someone has
modified some external state that you
depend upon so that would make your
function non-pure
what's also important is a pure method
must not call any non-pure method
so if that sounds like you can do some
sort of
uh analysis where if you if you flag
certain methods as pure
you can then build up call trees of
other methods that only call
other pure methods then that's
absolutely the case you you can do that
that provides you with a recursive
definition which you can use to to
determine statically whether methods are
appear or not
it's a very restrictive set of
conditions and in practice
it's you know
although you can do some things with
this
um
it actually really does just highlight
the difficulty of using the jvm for pure
functional programming
so
there's no support for it in the jdk
and there's no real sport for a jvm
level either so i think that that java
probably has to be given a failing grade
uh for its support of pure methods
okay
never mind let's move on immutability so
immutability you may well already know
about
an immutable object is one that can't be
a mutable object can't be altered after
creation which makes the code much
easier to reason about
the other way of thinking about this is
that the objects have a trivial state
model they're constructed in the only
state they will ever exist in
the big win is that if you have an
immutable object you can copy it you can
share it
you providing us a simple
straightforward object you might even be
able to to serialize it and move it
between vms you know so immutability is
a really really good thing
and it can be extremely helpful
unfortunately java doesn't have
as good a support for mutability as it
might do
it has final
but final is pretty fragile because it's
only the reference
that is immutable
you can have a final reference which
points at an object which is mutable
and a final reference to a mutable
object
well the mutable object can change so
even though that your reference is
holding steady
you can still have have changes in in a
a
of a mute of objects
so
all it takes is one mistake
and letting a small amount of mutability
creep in and a lot of your guarantees
are actually actually blown up
it's also worth noting that reflection
can also
get round
finality of reference
what's the big drawback with
immutability and why doesn't the jvm
really support it from ground up well
immutable objects cannot change state
that's kind of the point so if you want
a modified object how do you how do you
deal with with state changes the answer
is you have to create a new object
so basically to create a new object with
the changes that you want
and this puts pressure potentially large
pressure on the gc subsystem
this problem was a lot worse in the past
when memory sizes were a lot smaller
um but it's still not great today so
potentially we we actually will we'll
have
a lot of impact on garbage collection
and memory and allocation due to the
fact that we're creating lots and lots
of modified objects every time we want
to change
for those those people who are really
into
immutability one of the styles is to use
effectively what a factory method called
withers
um because you you create your object in
its its state like for example in the
java.dynapi you have the the dot of
methods which which are factories which
create the initial states of objects and
then you can create new objects by by
calling the these withers which
start.with so in the code example here
we set up a a date in 1984 and then we
can create a new object which points at
december by calling the with month
okay so how does java do on this one i
think we do reasonably well um yeah
given given how
middle aged chavr is as a language now i
think the fact that people could
couldn't have predicted that um
immutability would become such a big
thing and dealing with small vms and not
much memory where i think the
performance impact would have been
prohibitive in the early days to try to
do everything with immutable objects so
i think i think java you know certainly
doesn't get a failing grade it may not
be like the a grade that other languages
might get but i think i think actually
we are okay on this one
okay higher order functions now this is
um
actually a pretty straightforward idea
from the point of view of java or a
language like it a higher order function
is really just a function that either
takes a function as one of its
parameters
or
it returns a function
now in java's case that's that's
actually quite easy
because if you if you think about the
function type
which is present in uh in java util
function
what that means is is that a a
functional
type like like function for example is
going to show up as one of the generic
parameters to a function
so in this case this first example i'm
showing a function
which takes in a string
and returns another function
so i've called it prefixer
and what it does
is you give it a
string
which is the prefix
and it returns the code in the curly
braces which is a lambda expression
so it returns a function
which which uses the prefix
and and then just just prepends it on
the the start of the
whatever string you provide it
so this is a very simple example of a
function
that returns
another function
so this is sometimes called a generator
so you can generate functions using this
and i should also point out the um the
syntax here is a little little more
verbose than it needs to be you know
i've got the curly braces and the return
statement there actually
you can do better than that you can
actually write it just out like this
and
you know the this is this may look a
little more complicated to read
so i think it's okay if while you're
getting used to this type of syntax if
you actually write it in the slightly
more long hand and long-winded way on
the line above but these two definitions
are exactly equivalent um
there's just a bit of boilerplate
removed
so okay let's let's see how java does on
this well actually again
really pretty well
um so of course you can you can have
functions as
arguments to to generic types that's
that's how java works of course generic
supports that
uh there is a slight
hidden problem though with type erasure
here
probably don't have time to go into it
today
but it's fair to say that when you start
to do more complicated things with
higher order functions
java's type erasure unfortunately could
can give you a headache in a few cases
but still another area so that's i think
this is the second one now where we've
got some pretty uh reasonable um
passing grades for java as a language
what's next
recursion
okay so what's recursion well a
recursive function is one that calls
itself
okay so the standard example is a
factorial function which i think
everyone's probably seen loads of times
i've written this very simple version
here where you pass in a long number
n
which is less than zero the factorial
simple factorial returns one otherwise
it returns n times simple factorial
now
this is recursive but one of the things
that you might notice about it if you
look very carefully
is that the last thing that happens
is not the recursive call
because you make the recursive call the
value comes back and then it is
multiplied by n
so the last thing that this function
does
isn't
called itself
the last thing that it does is multiply
two numbers together
so for this reason um
it's actually sort of simpler if we if
we try to refactor and reformat
recursive functions into a form that's
called tail recursive
and the way that we do that in this
example is like this
so you've got a little helper function
um so that this one's called tail wreck
factorial
uh and now we have this this this helper
function called help fact
and if you notice it now takes two
arguments instead of one
but if you if you if you look closely
you can see that the very last thing it
does is a is a self-recursive call so
it's now this is this is it help factors
in the form that we call tail recursive
because the very last thing the function
does is call itself
um
i'm going to show a bit of bytecode so
don't worry if you can't read it it's
just really to show you that when you
write this out as bytecode it looks like
this and you can see that on on byte 14
the invoke static which is is the call
back to itself
so each time you go into this method
you're going to recursively call it
you're going to be building up frames on
the on the stack as you go through
okay
now if you look carefully
what you can see is that
you could actually change this a little
bit because when you when you call help
fact again what you're effectively doing
is you're just reusing the same function
so you could actually rewrite
the byte code
to avoid the invoke static
to avoid the self call and if you do
that the bytecode changes and it looks a
bit like this
because what we're doing is we're now
storing
the two numbers and then we
replace the invoke with a go to
which is an unconditional jump in in by
code
and what that means is we now have a
place where we we can we can get rid
of the the invocation um the problem
with with just having uncontrolled
recursion like you do in the java case
is that you run the risk if your stack
gets too big of having a stack overflow
in this rewritten version where we have
a go to instead of an invoke that no
longer happens
because this code now doesn't contain
any method implications so the stack
won't grow
so you could do this you could rewrite a
tail recursive call in this way
unfortunately java doesn't do that
javak always translates a function call
into an invoke
this means that tail recursion is not
optimized and can and will blow the
stack up with a a stack overflow
now
there are different arguments about this
in the design of java as it initially
was
the idea was to make it um transparent
if you're calling a function you are you
know which you do recursively you the
function call should put a frame on the
stack
the other way of saying that is that you
need to have stack trace validity you
need to be able to see the stack trace
frames on the uh on the stack there
this is not the only way to do it
other languages kotlin scala do things
differently and actually do do the
rewriting of the invoke into the go to
which we previously saw
not java however and so it gets a
failing grade for recursion
next up closures what's a closure the
closure is a lambda expression that
captures some state so
for example a little thing like this you
see we we have our in i is 42 and then
we have a lambda expression on the next
line f which captures it and i appears
as a
part of the
the lambda body
and this this will work fine if we run
this code of course it will print out
hello 42
but what happens if we uncomment the
line
um you you
maybe you know the answer maybe you
don't um so let me tell you if you
uncomment the line where we reset ie 37
after it's been captured by the lambda
what we end up with is a compiler error
java will not compile this code
afterwards it will say hey you know no
you're not allowed to do that after
you've captured a a piece of state
you can't reassign to it you can't you
can't re um modify the the contents of
that location
uh and so why is that well in order to
do that let's decompile the lambda
something you might not know is that the
lambda bodies are de-sugared they're
turned into a private static method
um
and then what happens is that the the
signature of the private static method
contains any variables that have been
passed as our arguments so if you're
capturing state it shows up as an
argument so in this case we're capturing
i which is of type int and that you can
see that that shows up in the signature
for the the lambda body method there
because there it is it's it's int it's
the
zeroth argument to this to this lambda
body
um so why do we do it this way why is it
constructed like this well
the answer is is that java is strictly
passed by value
okay
i actually sometimes refer to this as
pass by bit value or pass by bit copy
bitwise
copy what that means is that primitive
values are passed as the actual value
it's just a bit pattern
objects are passed as a bitwise copy of
the reference it's just a pointer
so what that means is if you make a
change to the primitive inside the
lambda body
it won't propagate back to call a
context because you just passed some
bits over you modified your local copy
of them but there's no
modification of the of the caller
context
the other way of saying that is that the
jvm has no native notion of what some
languages call an environment
in particular lisps and things like that
um so if you want to to to modify and
mutate state and have mutable state for
within your closure you must use a level
of indirection such as an atomic integer
and languages that do provide pass by
reference
and want to have mutable
closures that can change state in
another context they must provide that
at runtime
so
yes java does sort of have closures
um but if you talk to to some people in
functional programming and some some
list people in particular they'll get
very very angry if you describe
java's closures as being real closures
so this one is right on the fence this
is
i guess maybe a d minus is it quite a
failing grade it
very nearly is
um but but let's uh let's leave that one
and move on
laziness a value which is not computed
until needed
um the jvm has no inbuilt support for
these
the in general this is this is not an
easy thing to do well on the jvm and not
many
jvm languages support laziness directly
even clojure which is a lisp which is
and they're often lazily evaluated um or
have support for lazy evaluation i
should say uh even enclosure you you
don't you don't do laziness you only
have
lazy sequences there's no
general lazy values the only place we
really do see laziness is in the the
java streams api
where the runtime has been specially
designed and specially crafted to use
techniques of of laziness and late
evaluation
so again this is pretty close to a
failing grade for java here as well
next up currying and partial application
suppose we have a function or a method
with with several arguments two three
arguments
what happens if we supply some but not
all of the arguments to that to that
method or that function
if it starts off with two arguments and
supply one of them
i would argue that what you've done is
you've created a function of one
argument
and this is this is the the term that's
known as currying and the currying is
the reduction of a multi-argument
function into one with with fewer
arguments
um there's no automatic support for it
in the java language um java doesn't
actually have a complete set of general
function types the only ones it really
ships with are function and by function
and other other programming languages
may have more general versions
and the
other problem is that java syntax you
know you never get the sort of syntactic
sugar or the shortcuts that you do in
scala or in
uh in kotlin and if you if you are
calling a function you always have to
have an explicit method call on it
so you would have to do the same thing
with currying in java
so that's that's not very good um but
let's let's just take two seconds to see
what it would look like
here is the actual real interface for by
function
takes in an argument of type t and
argument of type u and it returns an r
so it's got the apply method there it's
also got a default method
so we might imagine that we could
actually add in
two other methods called curry left and
curry right
and what they do is they take in a
single value
and then they return a different
function but a function of one argument
now so remember the function took in a t
and a u
um and if you curry the left argument
and supply
an argument of type t
well then what we returned effectively
is a closure so this is a java closure
where we're capturing the value t and
returning a function of one argument of
type u
so that that basically is how you could
do this
for whatever reason the language
designers decided not to do this
there's no automatic support for it
there's no syntax support for it java
gets an f for carrying and partial
application
finally let's move on to talk briefly
about the java's type system and
collections there are three main issues
with core java that cause some problems
for functional programming the
non-single-rooted type system i.e the
fact that you have object which is the
the root of the object hierarchy but
then you have the primitive types which
don't have any inheritance relationship
to to object
there's also the fact that we have void
which means that java has both
statements and expressions
so another common fp paradigm
that people sometimes talk about is
everything is an expression
well not in java in java some things are
statements some things return void and
that can be a problem when you have to
model not only expressions but also
statements
finally there's the java collections
they are large interfaces they have many
methods on them the methods include add
and remove so all collections are
implicitly mutable
that isn't great
and what people were encouraged to do
before java 8
if they wanted a new a collection which
was not mutable was to simply implement
the mutability methods and throw
unsupported operation exception from
them
this of course is terrible
because it doesn't let you know whether
the the collection that you're looking
at is mutable or not by examining its
type
um and unsupported operation exception
is a runtime exception
so you don't even have the exception
signature to let you know that
potentially
this method might cause you problems
so you you'd start using an
implementation of the collection and
then all of a sudden you find out oh no
someone handed me a an immutable
implementation of this and i've just got
a runtime exception that's been thrown
from it
so
the collections are a great design from
20 plus years ago
they i think if they were reimagined now
people might well do things differently
uh but the collections are first class
they are embedded throughout the jdk we
are carrying 20 years of history here
the streams were only added recently and
they are not first class in the way that
the collections are
um the collections are never designed to
be functional containers you could not
realistically retrofit
any kind of functional programming
support on top of the way that the java
collections are written
so that's why we had to come up with
this concept of a stream
and streams i would say are closer to
being the sort of container types that
we want for functional programming
and overall
i think that we this is where we're
going to end up that java isn't really
that functional
you know we a couple of the properties
that we talked about earlier on java
gets a pass in grade four but for some
of them such as carrying especially
recursion cursion
it just gets a straight up fail grade
so
the key idioms like map and filter
reduce are there
but
the overall effect is really that that
java is i would say slightly functional
so we can add that to the the list of
properties that we can use to describe
java's type system
static nominal object imperative type
erased
modestly type inferred and now the last
one we're adding in slightly functional
so thank you very much i hope you
enjoyed the talk i have a new book which
is is amped in early access called the
well grounded java developer second
edition where i spend quite a bit of
time talking about some of the topics
that i've raised in in the talk today so
if you've enjoyed it please check out
the book there's also some great
sections on on kotlin and cloture as
well
thanks very much